what did you say that you've heard for
the X Factor she said it was like a
[ __ ] karaoke competition or something
to them I said it was a [ __ ] karaoke
competition but no it was very weird cuz
I had a contract for this series and the
goalposts kept moving we want you we
don't want you yeah we want you and we
don't know what we're gonna do with you
and then it was yeah we've come up with
what we're gonna do with you you're
gonna judge the judges oh wow they want
you to judge the judges yes so I they
wanted me initially to say that song was
wrong you shouldn't have given them that
song I thought you know your production
was [ __ ] you know it sounds so great
that was this and I just felt that was
just didn't feel good it seems
convoluted yeah it does and I think it
was because they had to pay me a lot of
money and I was there so they thought
well we might as well use it for
something I think right you want to do
something else and then just give you a
role because they're paying and then
they I saw the show one episode of the
show and then the next day I went in to
see how it and he said what's the show
that ish see in England where this show
is there aren't shows like this at
England so when people come on and you
talk but you talk real and it's like
you're talking to your mate yeah and
it's like we could be having dinner
right now it's dinner conversation you
know when you're didn't you say things
and you want to entertain each other and
right talk a little [ __ ] it's fun Jimmy
we don't talk about that we wouldn't
have this conversation at 10 in the
morning but we're comfortable we talk
yeah hey I was kind of disrespectful
which I was about the show yeah but you
were doing it casually not like making a
press statement exactly right and of
course Simon got upset
as she should pay me a lot of money you
know yada yada to make the decision to
fire you
sorry Simon is the one who made the
decision to fire you she said Simon
showed when Simon Says know what's this
season's don't be it's ITV no it's you
Simon had a baby with his best friend's
wife right yeah wife they knew he knew
the guy but he tried to tell you that it
wasn't it wasn't him that did it that
fires no
so anyway two weeks pass they call me up
it's coming near the time that I go and
do whatever they want me to do on the
show and they said it was really
disrespectful you know we don't know
what you're gonna do and I say we'll
leave it just leave it I honestly don't
care I'm not comfortable in the position
anyway ten days later they call me and
they go we don't really think that you
know we need you and I'm like fine just
keep sending the money it's fine later
and said darling I don't want to lose
you I want you to do the show
please come and do the show and I'm like
Simon if you feel this way in a week
call me you didn't hear back you got to
collect the money I just listened how
can you complain when I get to sit home
do nothing unfortunately unfortunately
and I'm only saying this not out of
malice I'm only saying this cuz Simon
quote Simon thinks it's funny that the
figures have dropped and dropped and
dropped through the course of the show
since you were gone yeah I'm not saying
it was old me at all but his decision to
change the show again and again yeah
many people who liked it or one way and
maybe they don't like what's turned into
and I mean as shows go on people get
sick of them singing shows it's like
we've seen so many
fifteen years and the show has made him
a fortune he's been hugely successful
and I read an interview he did the other
day and he says you know he thinks it's
funny that the ratings have dropped so
do I